Utah's calling Morita is on the line hi
Morita how are you hello Dave Ramsey I
am good thank you thanks so much for
taking my call and for all you do for
everybody we're on board and we're ready
to follow your steps
I'm honored how can I help today is it
okay to hold on to our $9,000 savings
while on step two it's okay to do
anything you're an adult but it's not
what we teach why would you do that I
just in fear of just in case an
emergency we just bought this home on a
FHA loan you know just barely into in
July of this year how much debt do you
have not telling the home not telling
the home we're at hundred twenty two
thousand eight hundred forty-six what's
that on that would be Best Buy which is
nine I mean 397 home people 457 no I
mean what's the big pieces yeah I know
hundred thousand our student loan or
something no we have a car loan of
24,000 to 63 there's a pension loan from
my husband's company for 24,000 there's
a court see in another state that we're
doing minimum payment on for 30 2006 34
gross a well there was a situation back
in 98 you know I did some time in you
know for for that crime it's not you
should get some rest at Ocean you're
paying off yes sir okay cool
and so that's that's 50 that's 85 those
three or 85 of your 123 what's your
household income my husband makes 90 90
ish 90 yeah that's a net do you work
outside the home be me I'm do I just
barely started a part-time job and that
will bring
10,000 and it's because I've been a home
mom for open time now our children are
in school and I found you on YouTube
just that recent time after buying a
house yeah I think that was God and
that's why I thank you this is this is
good so how long have you been out what
you said you did some time right yes sir
in 98 oh good a long time good yes and
you know whole new life now all right
yes sir wonderful that's wonderful good
and I get a paralegal degree so I just
graduated I did a two-year program and
I'm not yes I think I'm still needing to
learn more you know gain more knowledge
I think it'd be real valuable in a
defense attorneys office as a paralegal
yeah and you've got you got some chops
girl you know you know the you know the
ropes I think this is yeah this is great
it's a great time of your life well we
teach people to be down to $1,000 in
baby step one and apply the money to the
rest of it stop the borrowing be on a
budget together I think you've got the
opportunity to raise your income part
time up to thirty thousand if you is
your parent if your paralegal stuff
still working and you can do it in Utah
you just got to get you get your foot in
the door somewhere it may take you a
little bit of time to get there but I
don't think you've even got to work 40
hours to do that and I think you've
probably got some something to go along
with your academic knowledge and that's
called wisdom and wisdom comes from
experience mm-hmm I mean I think you
know some stuff right you been some
places you've seen some things you know
so and I think that's you know it's a
horrible thing that that is in the
rearview mirror but it's also it's also
a richness of your future potentially so
I think you got the opportunity to serve
some people in that way but yeah let's
let's get the income up let's get on a
tight budget and yeah I do I would take
you back down to baby step one
and I want to be part of you guys
helping to turn this around I'm gonna
put you through Financial Peace
University as as our gift at no charge
okay oh I really appreciate that thank
you so much sure my pleasure you hold on
you get your husband to go to class with
you now the two of you go and you let's
get those paralegal hours up I think
you're more valuable than you think you
are and I want to see you make some more
money because you need some more to tack
these debts and you may need to saw it
24,000 our car it might be stupid it's
pretty close to stupid it's not all the
way over there but it's you're in the
middle of a mess here and it's an
awfully expensive car and it's a fifth
of its ones it's 20% of your total debt
so something to think about and you got
a lot of debt but anyway let's let's
jump on this will show you how to do
every bit of it in Financial Peace
University Kelley will pick up and we'll
get you signed up